hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is the iPad air pretty simple not a
whole lot of surprises here but let's go
over what exactly that means basically
this is a bigger version of the retina
iPad Mini no I mean actually it is the
exact same hardware as the iPad Mini
with Retina display same proportions
same internals just stretched out into a
10 inch form factor instead of 8 inch
it's almost like someone huge stomped on
the new iPad Mini and flattened it out
and boom you got the iPad air so what
you're getting with this is a few new
things you get the thin bezels from the
iPad Mini you get the flat aluminum
unibody back panel in the design you get
the beautiful construction from the iPad
Mini and you get the extremely
reflective Apple logo from the iPad Mini
as well in fact it's probably easier to
just talk about the ways this is
different from the iPad Mini and those
would be the size and the battery so in
the size department obviously this is
the biggest change from all the other
iPads which is why they named it the air
when I could have easily named it the
iPad 5 but it's the air because it's
just 7.5 millimeters thin and only
weighs one pound so for perspective
that's the same thinness as the iPhone
5s and it weighs way less than any other
full-size tablet out there 30% less than
the all plastic Nexus 10 that's really
impressive so that plus the overall new
flatter shape of the tablet makes a
massive difference in how easy it is to
hold now I still prefer the soft touch
feel of tablets like the Nexus 10 for
watching a movie or holding a device up
for a long period of time but this new
shape of the air is a huge improvement
from the sharp corners of the previous
generation iPads and that's welcome I
just for the record I am NOT the norm I
don't have a normal hand size but this
is actually the first full size iPad
that I've been able to hold in one hand
but the truth is that something the iPad
keeps doing really well is the build
quality and this iPad air is no
exception it's beautifully crafted with
attention to detail everywhere and it
just screams quality at every corner
ASIS if you're still working on the new
Nexus 10 take notes so you know what I
do have to say it because this is a
thing that a surprising number of people
are actually concerned about but the
iPad air does have the best camera
I have ever used in a tablet like by a
lot it's a really good front and back
facing camera and that's all I'm gonna
say
not gonna tell you to use it not going
to tell you why it's good or how it
forms well in any situation I'm just
gonna say it takes better quality photos
and videos I might need to tell you how
I figured that out but look there are
some flaws here like there is no touch
ID and no fingerprint scanner where I
think it could have been most useful on
a tablet I mean how cool would it be for
a whole family to share an iPad and
they'd all log in with their
fingerprints and they never have to
worry about messy user switching that
would be awesome
oh well the next iPads will have it most
likely not a big deal I think my only
real gripe with the hardware that's not
actually nitpicking and I feel like I
say this about every iPad is the
speakers they're plenty big loud crisp
and clear but they're all on the same
side of the device the bottom which
means they fire sideways in landscape
mode and sideways audio in landscape
mode it drives me insane especially
because I've gotten so used to the Nexus
10's front-facing speakers but other
than that the hardware is great and the
software is iOS 7 it feels so
conservative I mean after using an
iPhone for a bit and now using an iPad
it almost feels really inefficient to
use iOS on this larger display in fact
iPads have the exact opposite problem
that Android tablets have right now on
an iPad everyone's home screen is
basically the same icons and folders
just like the phone home screen no
widgets no glanceable information just a
blown up phone interface the
Notification Center is just the iPhones
Notification Center blown up the quick
controls at the bottom are just the
phone's quick toggles blown up the
interface is exactly like the phone but
just spread out more it seems
inefficient it seems super wasteful but
when you dive into the applications one
of the many hundreds of thousands of
optimized applications for the iPad
you'll get some of the most impressive
functionality there's an insane wealth
of apps to choose from that are designed
specifically for the iPad and the Retina
display and when you open them you get
that entire display size they take up
the whole screen and use multiple
columns and gives you tons of
information at your fingertips in an
entirely different way than they ever
would on your phone this is the opposite
for Android tablets on Android tablets
the Play Store is
what's lacking the tablet apps and a
surprising amount of apps there are just
not optimized for the 10 inch display
and the high resolutions and using those
apps feels almost wasteful it seems like
you're wasting space but your home
screen is where you can really go to
town on the customization you can add
new icon packs and folders and launchers
and there's an insane wealth of widgets
and widget customization that you can do
to get glanceable information and
scrollable power at your fingertips so
I'm waiting for a middle ground and I'll
talk more about that in another video
but overall when you're actually using
these applications the iPad air is a
boss performer it's rocking that Apple
a7 chip and that's clocked at 1.4
gigahertz and it only has one gigabyte
of RAM but with that iOS style
multitasking gets about all you need and
I got to say this makes just about the
perfect handheld gaming device it has a
huge battery so you can gain forever it
has built strong and very very
lightweight so it's not going to fatigue
you to hold it and it has Apple's newest
gigantic chip in there which makes it a
great performer and it keeps frame rates
high and it has a huge
9.7 inch 2048 by 1536 Retina display 300
pixels per inch that creates essentially
the most immersive gaming experience of
any tablet out there next to the Nexus
10 when I mentioned the iPad air battery
life is notable that's because it's
great so in a device 7.5 millimeters
thin they managed to cram in 8820
milliamp hour battery and it goes four
days on a charge with regular use I've
charged mine exactly three times since I
got it more than a week ago and that's
what normal really heavy use that I put
into devices when I'm testing them and
when I use a device I really push it so
I've had this big beautiful Retina
display cranked all the way up in
brightness and I played games and I
browse the web and I played more games
and I browsed more and I played even
more games and browse even more and this
thing is just it does doesn't quit it
does not quit I actually had to try
really hard to burn through the whole
thing in a whole day and I was
unsuccessful I think if I maybe watched
a movie on a plane all day I could do it
but standby time is also incredible on
this thing you don't have to worry about
charging it at night put it to sleep
with 60% wake up the next morning 60% so
basically the strengths of the iPad air
are the performance and the build and
the weaknesses are
basically really all in the software
department for me also fun fact if you
want to crash an iPad running iOS 7 go
into the settings and tap brightness and
wallpapers twice it crashes every time I
don't know why but every time without
fail
it just happens so overall this is a
very familiar iPad experience if you
know iPad and you know you like iPad you
know you're going to like the iPad air
um if you had the iPad 1 this is going
to make a great upgrade if you have your
iPad 2 you're going to love this iPad
air iPad 3 or iPad 4 you're still going
to love this as an upgrade because it's
that much thinner and more importantly
lighter than all the rest of the
full-size iPads and that's why people
are going to buy they're not going to
see any sort of crazy interface
differences you're not going to see any
huge noticeable performance boosts
everything performs exactly as you would
expect because it's an iPad and that's
good and people like that overall though
I really like the iPad air and I love
love the hardware of the iPad air the
display is beautiful the backing is very
light I just like it it's not it's nice
it's nice to hold and it's nice to use
it makes me want to use it because of
its size but at the end of the day I'm
not really much of a large tablet person
meaning I don't use large tablets that
much I kind of love my 2013 Nexus 7 and
if I had to buy an iPad I would want a
smaller version of the iPad air which is
why the retina iPad Mini is in the mail
and if you want to see a comparison
between this and that be sure to leave a
thumbs up below but I do have more
content coming for you of the retina
iPad Mini but what that means is that
this one this exact one right here is
going to go up for grabs so be sure to
follow me on twitter at mkbhd if you
want to see details for that i'll have
the link right below that like button
and it'll be a basically Twitter
exclusive giveaway you'll have to watch
out there for all the full details and
read that very carefully so either way
this is when it is the iPad air thanks
for watching more videos like this to
come if you hit that subscribe button
you'll be first to see them and I'll
talk to you guys and
Aysen